I'll never forget playing the uh New
York Knicks Carmelo got the ball on like
the mid post kind of the block like he's
faced up boom two dribbles into me boom
boom missed the shot he's like that's a
foul to the rough rough and call the
foul we got the rebound we went down he
came back the next play went to the same
exact spot did the same exact move boom
boom made sure he got to follow I'm like
man what is this like come on man like
this dude just did the same exact move
to me like to make sure he get the file
called like don't get me wrong like I
filed him a little bit like don't trip
and what I took from that is like like
I'm not just gonna miss this shot you
think I'm gonna just miss that shot
without getting filed like and that
taught me something about confidence in
the NBA like that moment right there
like that was early in my career and it
taught me something about like being
great in confidence